bonjour nouvelle rentrée nouveaux thèmes
et nouvelles de tournage pour cet
épisode
tout le monde est bien installé que tu
que je dise je ne suis même pas descendu
mon canapé pour le déménagement
ouais on s'en souvient mais adenor ça va
je préférais la cheminée parfait on peut
commencer
cet épisode j'ai décidé de m'intéresser
aux tories 10 mhz parce que comme
beaucoup de groupes de pop ou de
croyance de l'antiquité on en a une
vision largement faussé à cause des
différentes réécriture réinterprétation
qu'ils ont subi ce genre panoramix mais
pas que on va donc faire le bilan de
toutes les croyances qui se sont succédé
sur les droïdes avant de présenter ce
qu'on sait réellement sur eux générique
[Musique]
la première chose à se demander c'est
qui a écrit sur les druides
est ce qu'il ya des observateurs
contemporains qui ont pris l'eau gelée
plume pour décrire leur rôle non pas toi
d'une fausse contemporaine la première
mention écrite des druides da du 3e
siècle avant jésus-christ dans le traité
grecque la magie bien avant la conquête
romaine donc on les retrouve dans
d'autres ouvrages règles du 2e siècle
avant jésus-christ comme le stroma thijs
l'histoire de la philosophie de
solutions d'alexandrie où l'histoire de
la philosophie de diogène laërce de la
philosophie
qu'est-ce que des barbares est à voir
avec la philosophie pour les graines ma
barrows dire étrangers qui ne partagent
pas la culture grecque
c'était plutôt neutres comme terme croit
pas mais comment elle cessa elle gélules
début du script
effectivement les grecs étaient en
contact avec le set au moins depuis
hérodote qui écrit sur eux au vème
siècle avant jésus-christ et donc nous
livre quelques descriptions 17 de leurs
moeurs et de leur religion
d'ailleurs pour faire simple et même si
c'est une généralisation puisqu'il était
constitué d'un grand nombre de peuples
on va dire que les gaulois sont des
sectes vivant en seconde âge de fer
entre moins 500 et le début de notre ère
en france belgique allemagne 6 rhénane
suisse et italie cisalpine les grecs
présente donc les druides comme des
philosophes reviendra sur leur rôle
précis plus tard mais ils sont comparés
à d'autres sages orientaux y comme
pythagore et ils sont parfois même
appelé les perles de la philosophie
rien que ça et en les présentant ainsi
les grecs semblent être plus proche de
la réalité que tous ceux qui leur ont
succédé dans son histoire de la
philosophie biogen et représente
plusieurs aspects de la sagesse
politique
déjà ils forment un ensemble un groupe à
part dans la société qui les passent
donc au dessus des autres
il s'adresse aussi aux hommes par maxime
propos énigmatique
parce que c'est vachement mystérieux ils
ont des principes simples honorer les
dieux ne pas faire le mal être brave et
ça peut sembler assez facile à suivre de
nos jours comme principe mais à l'époque
c'était déjà une sacrée réflexion sur la
vie ne pas faire le mal ça c'est plutôt
répondu chez nous grâce à la religion
judéo-chrétienne tu ne tueras point donc
à l'époque il fallait bien un philosophe
rouen c'est ça c'est à partir des
descriptions détruit par les romains que
les choses seraient tu ne sais pas s'il
y avait un but précis derrière la
description des druides mais pour les
romains c'est clairement le cas par
exemple césar lors de la guerre des
gaules en fait une description très
positif parce qu'il cherche à faire
passer les gaulois pour des gens un peu
civilisé il décrit donc les druides
comme des sages des éducateurs des
prêtres les gens bien quoi c'est
d'ailleurs à partir de césarée de
cicéron qu'on commence à décrire les
droïdes parce que dans les siècles
précédents pour les romains aucun
intérêt alors nous avions des rapports
diplomatiques et commerciaux avec les
gaulois
quel intérêt de savoir si le vénéraient
le temple m'acharne lieu chose et voilà
les gens sont pas intéressants tant
qu'on peut pas en tirer profit
telle mentalité et les romains oui mais
on s'y intéresse et ensuite on a même vu
un droïde divisia qui est venu à rome
nous a appris énormément sur son art
science chose les descriptions par les
romains restent vagues parfois inspiré
des écrits grecque mais plein
d'approximations par exemple c'est là
qu'apparaît le mythe du sacrifice humain
pratiqué par les druides et réduisant à
un rôle de grand prêtre et pourquoi les
descriptions des romains au 1er siècle
avant jésus-christ sont elles si vagues
et me direz vous c'est parce qu'à
l'époque qui avait déjà plus beaucoup de
doubler dans circulation en fait fini
l'âge d'or du druidisme tout ça mais on
reviendra dessus
pourtant pline l'ancien les capacités
ont écrit de si beaux textes sur les
druides tellement poétique poétique
c'est le mot mai
l'un fidèle à la réalité à partir du 1er
siècle après jésus-christ les druides
sont soient présentés comme des vieux
sages habillés en blanc soit comme des
barbares qui pratiquent le sacrifice
humain tout va bien je suis à deux jours
du départ là par exemple l'un des rares
témoignages sur des données dans
bretagne nous vient de tacite vers 140
après jésus-christ et décrit la prise de
l'île de mona par erreur sur le rivage
l'arménie faisait face dans son armée un
homme parmi elles couraient des femmes
semblables à des furies les cheveux des
loups et portant des torches
autour d'elle les druides les mains
tournées vers le ciel répandait
d'affreuses d'imprécations l'étrangeté
de ce spectacle ébranla des soldats qui
comme si leurs membres étaient paralysés
s'offrait aux coûts sans bouger dès lors
une garnison fut installée chez les
ennemis et leurs bois sacré voué à de
sauvages superstition furent rasés
car ils croyaient pieux d'honorer leur
hôtel du sang des prisonniers et de
consulter les dieux dans leurs
entrailles
alors tu as si t'étais pas là il raconte
les événements 50 ans après et rien que
le fait que les druides était
apparemment dispensé de service
militaire nous fait dire qu'elle est le
fait qu on ne sait même pas s'il y avait
des doutes sur l'île alors ils étaient
encore mois au lieu des combats d'une ou
des choses que tu sais alors pas du rien
je déconstruis un mythe comme la faute
si à votre époque personne ne
s'intéressait au boulot la culture
antique s'avoue pas c'est bien au-dessus
pardon et qu'est ce que tu fais de jofra
mouloud dans son histoire de la bretagne
par le 17 et des droïdes
il explique que l'ancêtre des bretons
des sens des nerfs en personne et par
d'arthur aux signes de myrdhin une
espèce de prêtre guerrier qui
l'accompagnent et qui a inspiré le
personnage de merlin qui est un mythe
ce bon je peux continuer les textes en
titre et temps des gaulois sont surtout
redécouvert durant la renaissance on
s'intéresse aussi aux ruines dès l'été
de l'antiquité mais c'est à cette époque
qu'apparaît le légère anachronisme qui
veut que les dolmens et menhirs et été
construite par des gaulois il ya juste
au moins 3 millions d'écart entre les
domaines et les premiers vont loin c'est
pas grand chose après tout cependant le
courant humaniste du 16e siècle
s'intéresse davantage aux grecs et aux
latin cool ce qu'il représente un modèle
plus intéressant assure apparemment du
coup pendant une longue période les
gaulois et les dribbles sont encore mis
de côté d'ailleurs à cette époque on ne
parle pas de nos ancêtres gaulois
jusqu'au 19ème siècle on préfère dire
qu'on descend des francs c'est quand
même un petit peu plus classe que des
cendres de marc barr moustachu ça tombe
bien cette image là apparaît au 19e
siècle en plein roman national à une
époque où on essaye de trouver aux
français des ancêtres combatif pour se
mettre bien face aux autres peuples
on a déjà un peu parlé dans ma petite
vidéo sur le roman national donc je vais
pas m'attarder sur la vision des gaulois
au 19e siècle
et pour ce qui est des druides leur
importance est grandement minimiser à
cette époque par les historiens du roman
national vu l'importance des druides
dans la société vaudoise ça coulait pas
vraiment avec l'image de guerriers pas
très instruits que voulait créer
michelez et compagnie alors ou réduit
des druides à des vieux barbus habillés
en blancs qui vivent dans la forêt
écueils du guilly avec une serre c'est
dommage parce qu'on 1828 l'historien à
médiers thierry avait écrit l'histoire
des gaulois que je n'ai pas lu mais qui
apparemment était assez proche de la
réalité
enfin toujours est il que l'image des
droïdes continue d'inspirer de
nombreuses personnes auteurs jusqu'à des
groupes se revendiquant du néo druidisme
comme le to readers hub qui existe
depuis 1716 et vise à restaurer la
tradition de riddick et en parlant de
tradition que je pense qu'il serait
temps de présenter qui était réellement
les droïdes ouais ça va bien cinq
minutes l'historiographie veut des films
dans ce cas on va commencer notre
présentation des druides par un point
étymologie
les droïdes se font eux-mêmes appelée
torride c'est un bon gaulois mais dont
les racines sont probablement grecque
il peut venir d'une grue et signifie
chaîne par rapport à la forêt que les
wade aime tant et de valdes qui signifie
voir et savoir ça donnerait donc le
savons par le chêne
c'est joli mais ça veut pas dire grand
chose ça c'est l'interprétation antique
ou 19e siècle linguiste rudolf sur mason
suggère queudrue serait en fait une
particule qui renforce le mot ça
donnerait donc le très savant un peu
plus de sens mais ça reste une théo les
droïdes était sûrement les héritiers
d'autres personnalités importantes
durant l'âge de bronze
parce qu'un groupe d'une telle
importance n'a pas pu apparaître un
katmandou il était très probablement
inspiré dans leurs idées et leur mode de
vie par le philosophe pythagore dont il
connaissait l'existence
il est possible que des douilles et des
rencontres et des élèves de pythagore et
on trouve de nombreux points communs
entre les deux groupes
déjà la croyance en la réincarnation et
l'immortalité de l'âme qui dirait
incarnation dit recherche du bien pour
sortir du cycle de réincarnation et
atteindre une sorte de paradis encore
une idée nouvelle ces idées sont
développées par pythagore et par les
droïdes qui pensent que la fin du monde
amènera la destruction des âmes
immortelles comme les pythagoriciens des
droïdes s'interroger sur la nature de
l'univers il s'habiller en blanc pour
montrer leur pureté et divulguer leur
enseignement en secret dans des endroits
reculés et à l'oral uniquement par
contre les pythagoriciens avec druide
n'occupait pas la même place dans la
société
une autre différence entre les 2 tient à
leur alimentation et à leur rapport aux
sacrifices josue beghal pythagore
encourager le végétarisme était contre
le sacrifice des animaux parce que l'âme
de l'animal avait peut-être appartenu et
un humain avant alors ça se faisait pas
trop
fily sétois
les druides n'était pas d'accord avec ça
et penser qu'un homme se réincarner
forcément en sommes donc tout le reste
on pouvait le manger des tweeds était
très impliqué dans la société gauloise
il avait une importance dans le domaine
de la religion d'abord puisque leur
présence était nécessaire aux sacrifices
aux cérémonies religieuses et c'est
également eux qui décident et
l'emplacement des sanctuaires gaulois au
hasard dans la forêt oui mais le lieu
exact dépend des deux questions
astronomique de calcul etc bref il n'y
avait pas de religion de riddick en
déplaise aux romains mais une religion
gauloise dans laquelle les druides avait
une grande importance
je trouve que mon peuple et par peu trop
déconsidérer dans cette vidéo puisque
les druides sont calés en astronomie
il met aussi leurs connaissances en
application pour réaliser des
calendriers perpétuels comme le
calendrier de collinwood dans lequel un
siècle dure trente ans il prend en
compte les cycles solaires et le nom
c'est formidable comme ça les gueuses du
moyen-âge oro s'est vanté de vivre un
siècle
il pratiquait aussi la physiologie qui
était un mélange de géologie de
botanique de zoologie de chimie bref
qu'ils étaient calés pour en arriver à
un tel niveau de connaissance il fallait
qu'ils aient reçu un enseignement solide
l'initiation des druides et des longues
et confidentielle litres la formation
dure et 20 ans était réservée à l'élite
gauloise on ne sait rien sur les
conditions matérielles de cette
formation
si les élèves nés chez leur maître
pendant ce temps on s'il avait plusieurs
mètres selon les spécialités
comme il n'y avait pas de vie
communautaire chez les droïdes pouvait y
avoir une maison fondée
lui il n'avait pas non plus une école de
riddick et la formation se faisait à
l'oral pour rester confidentielles les
druides tenais tellement secret que les
interdisait carrément l'écriture à toute
la population vos lois comme ça en prend
bonne note mais s'il devait communiquer
avec d'autres peuples
oui là y'avait exception pour les
commerces aussi fallait bien passer par
les tri dans ce cadre là c'était toléré
tu as parlé de calendrier rédigés par
des droïdes tout à l'heure là aussi les
deux rives et les autres d'écriture mais
pour eux pas de problème on suppose
qu'il y avait différentes communautés de
dominique dirigé par un maître avec
peut-être parfois des divergences entre
les idées des différentes communautés et
en certaines occasions ces groupes se
réunissent et puis attendez c'est un et
du 1 qui entre dans un bar on ne peut
savoir ce que tu fais je me prépare pour
un rassemblement de runic lust ont
baissé sans alcool durant ces
rassemblements une rendent la justice a
tellement la grosse ambiance existe
aussi des assises annuelles en pays
carnutes habilement dom et les assises
des carnutes temps pourra pas rester
debout
les gaulois et s'est divisé en plein
peuple mais ils avaient en commun une
religion et des druides qui assurait
donc l'unité spirituelle de tous les
gaulois pour un temps tout ce que j'ai
présenté jusqu'à présent sur le rôle et
le mode de vie des droïdes
c'était avant la conquête romaine à
partir du 2e siècle avant jésus-christ
l'importance des druides commence à
décliner
probablement parce qu'il prenait un mode
de vie tourné vers la gauche pour la
gaule sur le boul alors qu'à partir du
deuxième siècle les gaulois commencent à
se tourner vers la méditerranée
il crée des contacts diplomatiques et
commerciaux des divisions apparaissent
aussi avec la création d'une province
romaine dans le sud-est des invasions
par l'est des luttes internes certains
peuples gaulois reviennent à des régimes
politiques anciens comme la royauté ou
d'autres sont inspirés par les romains
et se rapproche de la démocratie le
milieu tout ça allait trouver non plus
vraiment leur place
bref la boutique est fermée adressez
vous à un concurrent champs les grands
rassemblements de rue dicks s édifice
yak le saint louis dont on est un
témoignage à travers si c'est vous qui
vivez au premier siècle avant
jésus-christ continue à se faire appeler
torride mais n'a gardé que deux aspects
de cette pratique sa formation
scientifique et intellectuelle et la
divination n'a plus de rôle religieux
moralisateur et donc droid est surtout
devenue une position honorifique à son
époque pourtant su est un état si ton
bien dit que le druidisme avait continué
clandestinement souvent pire mara c'est
faux mais ça fait toujours bien de
raconter qu'on a les ennemis clandestins
à vaincre par ci par là
certaines personnes continuent de se
faire appeler très bien après le 1er
siècle mais ils font ça dans leur coin
maintenant des femmes druidesse
apparaissent aussi savoir c'est
largement perdu les druides de gaulle et
de bretagne qui était un petit peu moins
développé que leurs confrères s'efface
définitivement au ivème siècle après
jésus-christ et même le mode reid
disparaît de la langue danoise à partir
du viiie siècle les moines irlandais se
remettent à parler de droid qui ont des
pratiques magiques avant d'être converti
au christianisme mais il s'agit d'une
réutilisation tardive d'un mot qui n'a
plus beaucoup de sens à cette époque
pour résumer les doigts de scientifiques
leverett et des philosophes religieux en
politique astrologue scientifiques qui
ont vécu entre le 5e et 2e siècle avant
jésus-christ et qui n'en fait que
décliner jusque là c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui merci d'avoir suivi cet
épisode et c'est moi ça épisode dumas
prochain portera sur un sujet mystérieux
intrigant mais si vous avez aimé cet
épisode je peux vous conseiller jean
louis brunaux qui a beaucoup effet sur
les druides et kim a reculé du coup pour
cet épisode
de par ce livre est aussi par hasard le
numéro de l'histoire de septembre porte
sur l'île aux noix et les druides
ce qui tombe plutôt bien rester fort
intéressant à lire rendez vous donc le
1er novembre normalement et en attendant
je vous laisse préparez vos meilleures
blagues pour le prochain rassemblement
de riddick
[Musique]
gobeil morning croatie face à chrome os
morgane à promouvoir comme le meilleur
[Musique]
morgan crown voirie au vol ça brasse nos
maux morgenstern avoir comme cette ce
maïs père est frais
[Musique]
ouais
au tie break face à croire aux nouveaux
membres jean pronovost comme cette
soirée fruits
[Musique]